there are 500 million people from 27
countries
living in the european union we have the
right to live
work travel and shop anywhere in europe
we make over a billion cross-border
trips every year
and 12 million of us live in another eu
country
but sometimes we face barriers to our
rights and our freedom to move across
europe
the european union is working to make
sure everyone benefits from the same
rights
in everyday situations
your personal data will be safeguarded
seventy percent of eu citizens are
concerned that their personal data may
be misused
that's why the eu is working to
strengthen your right to access
change or delete your data as well as
the right to be forgotten
letting you remove data after you no
longer want it to be used
as a european citizen your rights are
protected
at home abroad and online